bonjour jean marc bonjour à vous ravi de
vous retrouver dans la matinale rt
france est-ce qu'on peut chiffrer déjà
les conséquences sur l'économie de la
reprise de cette pandémie va écouter
tout le monde et sur sa machine à
calculer avant parce que tant que le
risque se limitait à la cinquième vague
du virus et bien les chefs d'entreprise
ont considéré qu'elle qu'elle n'aurait
pas d'impact parce que ils savaient que
les vaccins nous protéger donc pas de
panique mais au même moment on a appris
donc que ce variant sud-africain rodet
est allé en arriver en europe personne
ne le connaissait mais tout le monde
s'est interrogé sur sa méchanceté du
coup principe de précaution oblige tout
le monde s'est mis à angoisser et les
moules gouvernement on le voit bien on
commençait à se barricader par icade et
leur territoire dans l'espoir d'empêcher
l'arrivée du virus résultats bien des
secteurs entiers de l'économie sont en
train de s'arrêter de nouveau les
voyages aériens notamment de longue
durée regarder à destination du maghreb
sont arrêtés sont annulés les uns après
les autres les hôtels qui s'attendaient
à des fêtes de fin d'année à peu près
normal les stations de ski aussi vont se
remettre en mode je veux pas dire
confinement mais quasi confinement les
problèmes d'approvisionnement dont on
pouvait penser qu'il serait amorti avant
la fin de l'année vont perdurer comme
les tensions d'ailleurs qui existent sur
le prix des énergies fossiles et
notamment des des carburants avaient des
problèmes de demandes voire des
problèmes d'offre aulas et de livraison
bref la plupart des acteurs vous retenir
un certain nombre de leurs projets
d'investissement en attendant d'y voir
plus clair les début de l'année 2021
trop sans doute moins brillant que ce
qu'on espérait les risques d'inflation
les risques d'approvisionnement les
menus des risques sanitaires bas vont
bousculer toutes les prévisions et jean
marc est ce que ça veut dire qu'on
pourrait retomber dans le climat
angoissé de la dernière sans doute pas
je pense que que noël mais va quand même
noël vacants est un peu plombé cela
étant le moral n'est pas retombée
actuellement dans le pessimisme du début
de la pandémie d'abord parce que la
plupart des chefs d'entreprise ont
appris à résister avec des moyens
renouveler adapté télétravail on sait
faire la digitalisation on est très en
avance ensuite tout le monde a acquis la
conviction que le risque d'un
confinement total était totalement
exclue aujourd'hui enfin parce que le
ministre de l'économie a eu bill t vous
avez vu cette semaine de monter au front
très rapidement de préciser que le
gouvernement allait reprendre les aides
en faveur des secteurs qui seraient
contraints de mettre un genou à terre
bref on va laisser certaines perfusion
branché du côté des assedic par exemple
ou des pg e les plans d'aidé d'epargne
des plans de les prêts aux entreprises
bien on va rester très souple et
pragmatique pour bruno le maire la
priorité à ses préserver à la fois les
actifs de production mais surtout aussi
le capital de confiance faux pas
démoraliser des gens parce que ça
alimente la résilience donc le monde de
l'entreprise ne se gagne pas en revanche
en revanche je peux vous dire que la
perspective d'une campagne
présidentielle les préoccupent davantage
avant quelle raison le lait les acteurs
de l'économie pourrait-il s'inquiéter
d'une campagne précis parce que de façon
générale les économies n'aime pas les
campagnes les campagnes présidentielles
parce que on a quand même tendance à
rapport raconter un peu n'importe quoi
d'abord vous voyez bien que l'offre
politique qui est très éclaté en france
avec des courants idéologiques très
hétéroclite qui par sa part un peu dans
tous les sens tout ça y compris pour le
président sortant qui n'a pas de
majorité très homogène très solide le
mouvement en marche est très fragile on
se demande avec quelle majorité pourra
gouverner s'il est réélu par exemple la
droite a l'air désignations champions le
week-end prochain difficile de prévoir
qui va sortir de ces urnes de la
primaire l'emporter et avec quelles
lignes surtout il défendra la gauche
social-démocrate a disparu mais
l'amygdale go n'existe plus reste
l'extrême gauche à l'extrême droite et
les écologistes qui sont chacun dans
leur couloir de nage avec leurs propres
problèmes et dieu sait si leur nom il
n'y a pas de candidat aujourd'hui dans
le discours duquel des chefs
d'entreprises pourraient se reconnaître
j'ajoute qu'on ne peut pas espérer un
compromis entre tous ces gens qui ne se
respecte pas on n'est pas en allemagne
sais pas si vous avez vu en allemagne
qui s'est passé on a réussi à faire des
alliances entre des parties très
différents sur un programme de
gouvernement pendant la période pendant
du mandat
d'autant ajouté un deuxième risque c'est
celui évidemment de la démagogie la
concurrence entre tous ces candidats va
se jouer non pas sur des programmes de
gouvernement responsable d'où la
difficulté de ce fameux compromis mais
sur des promesses électorales qui se
révéleront inapplicable
on voit déjà que les thèmes de débat qui
émerge actuellement dans les formes et
dans les présentations très violente
l'immigration la question du pouvoir
d'achat tout ça est difficile on a du
mal à trouver une cohérence dans tout ça
les propositions sont sans nuance et
puis tous ces partis vont éviter de
parler des sujets qui fâchent et ça
c'est très important ils sont pourtant
incontournables les sujets qui fâchent
c'est quoi ces relations internationales
c'est la gouvernance européenne c'est le
rôle de l'allemagne ce sont les
relations avec la russie avec la chine
avec les problèmes pétroliers les
problèmes d'énergie tous ces sujets sont
incontournables parce qu'ils impactent
directement notre vie quotidienne notre
avenir et surtout l'avenir des
entreprises alors
j'ajoute qu'on peut pas espérer je
disais tout à l'heure il ya un compromis
entre tous ces gens deux parties puisque
ces gens là ne s'aiment pas beaucoup il
dispute pas ont une fois de plus on
n'est pas en allemagne qui avait réussi
à faire des alliances très forte je
crois que d'une façon générale les
promesses électorales servent à attirer
les voix c'est normal en démocratie bien
sûr mais si elles ne sont pas appliquées
la rue va se venger par des mouvements
plus ou moins spontanés qui pertube
paralyse l'activité économique comme ce
fut le cas avec les gilets jaunes mais
si les promesses inapplicable sont
néanmoins appliquées il faudra des
financiers et on les finance comment de
l'impôt donc dans les deux cas ça coûte
cher ça coûte extrêmement cher à tout le
monde mais d'abord à tous ceux qui
travaillent non les chefs d'entreprise
n'aime pas les campagnes électorales
donc le début de l'année prochaine ça va
être compliqué pour eux merci beaucoup
jean-marc l'élite aux échos jean marc
sylvestre c'est tous les mercredis matin
dans la matinale sur des france